texas quarterback deshaun watson
reacting to some chatter on friday
regarding the bears evaluation of
quarterbacks in 2017 points out the
bears never once talked to me never once
all caps that's desean watson saying
that the bears never once talked to me
well never let max get in the way of a
good story because here we are
uh back in 2017
desean watson said he spoke to the bears
ravens chargers on the phone it's also
my understanding they talked to him at
scouting combine they did talk to him
they did evaluate him and i'm not saying
deshawn watson is deliberately
misremembering look there are all sorts
of reasons why we recall events a
certain way the human mind is imperfect
sometimes it's just to bolster a desire
to go out there and push yourself to a
higher level right if you constantly use
the fact that the bears took a
quarterback other than you
and their quarterback stinks and you
ended up being good to motivate you to
be the best player you can be so be it
people find motivation and things like
that all the time chris this one is
strange it's unusual and it it's it's
it's it's strange to see deshawn watson
do anything in all caps he doesn't seem
like an all-caps kind of guy he seems
very low-key very even-keeled that's
what surprised me about this more than
anything more than him being factually
wrong three years later which happens
the fact that he's riled up about it he
doesn't seem like a guy who gets riled
up about anything
well you know when dabo sweeney says
though he's like a michael jordan that
tells you he's got to be some edge to
him certainly and that winning is
important or you know feeling slighted
certainly can motivate him i'm with you
though like deshawn watson is you know i
mean is the first time i feel like we've
caught him in a little bit of a bs trap
right just a little bit he's never been
one to one attention to himself or
anything like that he's one of my
favorite players to watch in all
football he's amazing that way but yeah
i think this is a simple case of an
athlete just looking for anything to
kind of piss themselves off give them a
little chip on their shoulder
just to motivate them and that's very
understandable that's what does happen
you know also you know i think he
probably embellished because i do know
the bears were doing their
due diligence to desean watson the one
thing i don't know if the bears did to
where i bet you deshawn watson feels a
little cheated is i don't know if they
went down and visited desean watson did
things like that had a private workout
that i'm pretty sure they did not and i
think probably from that aspect and the
fact that whoa they took a guy in
mitchell trubisky where you know i
performed in that same conference at a
way higher level for years and years uh
and trubisky just is kind of a one-hit
wonder in college football yeah i mean
he probably just feels cheated and
pissed off about that in general
there are people out there who wonder
whether or not deshaun watson will be
the quarterback in houston
for the remainder of his career or more
importantly for that second contract and
when you see guys like deandre hopkins
get traded
you know i don't know until desean
watson signs a second contract i'm not
going to assume that he wants to stay
because look chris if the starting
quarterback's not all in if the starting
quarterback wants out you got a problem
you got to accommodate him because
your guy who shows up early and stays
late and serves as the the coach who
also plays who holds teammates
accountable and does all the right
things if he doesn't want to be there
you got a problem and i'm not saying he
doesn't there have been flashes there
have been questions there was some stuff
in the aftermath of the hopkins trade
that made me think what's up here with
deshaun watson and when we see
him peel back a little bit and show us
that there is a a fire that is raging
below that very serene surface
i'm not ruling out the possibility ends
up somewhere else are you
well i i think it's unlikely you know i
i just have a hard time you know one
you know he's already kind of made an
imprint on the city of houston he's he's
the biggest star in town i mean yeah i
know they got james harden there and
everything for the nba and basketball
and all that but texas is a football
state houston's a football city and
deshawn watson is a star i just have a
hard time thinking that he won't be
there you know and mike you know again
i know the hopkins things happen but you
know they're doing their best down there
to put talent around him again he's got
three good receivers around them they're
improving their offensive line they got
david johnson in there they're making it
about deshawn watson and his ability to
be the quarterback and be successful and
carry the team through the offensive
side of the ball a little like we see my
homes do with kansas city so i have a
hard time thinking that he'd go
somewhere else i i do i just think he's
you know these type of marriages don't
happen often houston had to be crazy to
let him out of the building and you know
he started something special there what
what do you want to say
if they should reach an impasse at some
point in their contract negotiations
between now and the point at which the
franchise tag would be applied the
chicago bears could always make an offer
right they could put your right to rest
once and for all couple of first-round
draft picks maybe something more for
desean watson if jaylen ramsey is worth
two ones and a four deshawn watson is
worth at least that much
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports